what a giant oil rig needs to be dropped  in the ocean hundreds of miles offshore  how do you move it meet the dockwise  Vanguard the world's largest heavy lift  ship with 63 thousand metric tons the  unique ship was built in South Korea and  costs 200 million dollars to put  together the dockwise Vanguard is 900  feet long and 230 feet wide it can carry  up to a hundred 10,000 tons of weight  that's more than the weight of the  Eiffel Tower the ship works by moving  alongside its cargo filling its ballast  tanks with water and submerging 250 feet  below the surface from there at  manoeuvres beneath the cargo and empties  its ballast tanks  rising back to the surface and lifting  the heavy cargo with it the ship can  travel up to 16 miles an hour with the  massive cargo on its deck and can also  act as a dock for ocean-going  maintenance crews the dockwise Vanguard  greatest feats so far moving the 56  thousand metric tons AK st. mallow the  largest oil platform ever built